Amid this spring’s teacher walkouts, the
outlines of a sensible deal on teacher pay
seem pretty clear.
First, there’s a need for additional taxpayer
support.
Terrific teachers are woefully underpaid and, in many states, average pay should be substantially higher.
Second, an across the board increase isn’t
the whole answer.
Some lousy teachers are currently overpaid,
even as exceptional teachers are wildly underpaid.
Current pay scales simply
don’t create room to use or appropriately
compensate teachers who are doing great work.
New taxpayer investment should help change
that reality.
Third, retirement benefits for educators
cost twice as much as those for other workers.
Teachers need to do their part, and agree to overhaul outmoded and expensive pension systems.
Doing so will help free up substantial dollars for teacher take-home pay.
Such a deal on taxes, pay systems, and pensions
involves short-term sacrifices.
But such a bargain has the potential to yield
big benefits for students, teachers, and taxpayers.
Do you think we should raise teacher pay? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.